hey don't Eridani O'Dwyer here live from
suplex City when my man Sheamus how are
you how you doing great sell yourself a
grand I wanted I haven't seen you in
years I saw you once back when you were
called Sheamus O'Shaunessy well you know
drop yellow shadow see like well you
obviously haven't touch up the old war
tell Oni like one names in WVUE that's
your Johnson already order so it's
always wonderful to meet a fellow
Irishman they're far away from home and
what do you think it is about I mean
when it comes to combat sports and Irish
people we're not we're not sure we got
Colin in the Olympics getting well
getting screwed over but doing well
believable by the way what a joke that
was not harboring his reaction though
yeah it was great like most people to be
like just suck it in and just take it
easy like oh they know I wonder boy I
want boom boom it's great
why not that's passion he's passionate
about what he does he should have been a
goal where he shouldn't want the goals
like it's get screwed over by a boat to
politics and corrupts I mean corrupt
officials which pulling up were all sent
home anyway I know the opponent goes
home boy was the boy back in the
Olympics will it show what a joke
Olympics every year every four years to
me lifted the I don't know respect to a
hybrid Olympics goes down more and more
obviously you know you are you're one of
our country's premier athletes one of
our country's premier fighters what do
you think of young mr. McGregor on the
other side of the country trying to do
his heart against mr. Diaz never showed
to up anyway that's one thing a
Stephanies never filter on I mean I mean
probably learned up from from you guys
talking you know representing Dublin on
the international stage it sounds like
it sounds like he wants a job but w/e I
don't know what he's too confident the
point but says he wants a job but I'm
sure if you want a one day bring him in
you know it's definitely crazy says a
lot of controversial thinks he's a never
showed up
so I mean he's brings a lot of attention
it's oh he's a showman you know Naveen
which is what we do as well you know but
it can handle are scheduled I don't know
like
right we're never home I go home darling
maybe for a couple of days every year
most type of lucky buddha I'll be
interesting tomorrow night but Belgium
as far as I'm concerned you can have
your USC 202 Summer Slam is way bigger
it's been around longer and it'll be
around a lot longer after USC is in the
dirt
how was your eyes doing it's okay so
cupola focal cupola fuchal that's it not
really much you not I mean come on Laura
Connor Connor Street onto the Marcus to
hane the better come on freshen oh boy I
got my respect I do miss it I got there
in Spanish too because Veronica down
there wants to learn Spanish
you see Veronica no Bryce Veronica do
their ponytail oh and we're learning
Spanish words work for there in Spanish
for ya so my pleasure to talk to you my
friends all more this weekend thanks
very much
oh yeah oh yeah wb2k 17 in stores
October 11th pre-order now get Bill
Goldberg there is no better game if you
look W e there's not close to the real
thing that's where we were me I was
weird
I've no closer than the came with to
case every day to what we do on the ring
Bella